candidata por este distrito frente
amplio lorena fría esa es una de las
feministas históricas de chile piel
luchadora por los derechos humanos de
las mujeres y pro aborto con su carrera
ahora de la posibilidad de contribuir al
cambio en chile en estas elecciones
presidenciales y parlamentarias va por
un puesto de diputada en el congreso
debería votar por mí porque llevo
muchísimos años trabajando en el mundo
en los movimientos sociales feministas y
de derechos humanos hay que llevar a la
práctica e implementar esa convención
esa nueva constitución que va haber que
defender esos derechos humanos y el
feminismo con uñas y dientes en el
parlamento para muchos la esperanza del
feminismo está puesta en esa nueva
constitución que se empieza a redactar
en chile la primera que será paritaria
en el mundo y también contará con
participación de la ciudadanía como en
este cabildo ciudadano
giovanna roa es una de las 155 elegidas
para redactar el texto destinado a
enterrar la dictadura de pinochet con
una trayectoria como dirigente
estudiantil y feminista se asegurará de
que las leyes pueden traducirse a la
práctica vamos a impulsar la agenda de
derechos sobre nuestros cuerpos no de
una educación sexual y reproductiva de
tener una salud digna que nos pueda
permitir también poder ejercer nuestro
derecho y por supuesto una igualdad
sustantiva en el trabajo también esa
agenda va más allá de la igualdad busca
la justicia social aunque las
convencionales serán claves ya hay
mujeres feministas que ocupan espacios
de poder como la primera alcaldesa
comunista de santiago irás y hasler
electo también en mayo pasado creo que
chile ha tenido un movimiento de mujeres
y feminista muy fuerte en los últimos
años que es el que ha logrado tener hoy
día una constitución paritaria y tener
un debate público nacional donde las
mujeres nos estamos empoderando y
estamos avanzando en nuestra autonomía
los avances son indudables también las
amenazas
de la ultraderecha en las encuestas y en
la calle preocupan las feministas que no
están dispuestas a dar de ninguna forma
ni un solo paso atrás
en chile que soy llamado
distintos barrios de la comuna de
santiago